Bones rely on connective tissue made of proteins like
collagen, to remain strong and resistant to fractures. And,
mutations that affect the way collagen coils into a
triple helix, can affect the strength and integrity of
bones in such a way that causes osteogenesis imperfecta,
or brittle bone disease. The gene that codes for
the Alpha one component of type one collagen is
COL1A1 and it's essential for building the collagen fibers,
like you see here. Normally in the form
of a triple helix. If you follow the colors
closely, you can see the red spiralling around
the structure and the green and the blue doing
the same thing. The COL1A1 gene can be
found on chromosome 17 in the human genome. Chromosome
17 is about 81,000,000 base pairs long and the
COL1A1 gene can be found about halfway down. The
COL1A1 gene spans 51 exons and over 18,000 base pairs of DNA.
After transcription and splicing, the mRNA
has 4,395 nucleotides of coding region between
the start and stop codons. And after translation, we get a protein
with 1,464 amino acids. Remember, we just divided 4,395 by three, and subtracted
one because this last codon doesn't code for
an amino acid. The stock codon is just empty.
Now most of the amino acids in the collagen
molecule itself are glycine. Because this is actually what
allows the collagen to form that beautiful triple helix
we solve that's sort of turning back on itself.
A lot of glycines make that possible. So, any
allele that might disrupt the glycines in these positions
are associated many times with Osteogenesis Imperfecta. But one
mutation of the COL1A1 gene contains a G to T, a
guanine to thymine mutation at position 1245 of the coding region. Now, using
the genetic code, which we learned about in
lesson three, and that you can find in
the instructor's notes on this page, I want
you to determine the expected amino acid change from
the top to the bottom sequence. And then select the
type of mutation that best categorizes this change to the
T allele. If you have any trouble answering this, you
might want to go back and review mutations from lesson six.